what I see in Trump is a set of skills
that are so deep and so exquisite it
would be hard for me to imagine anybody
beating him and so I've predicted he'll
go all the way and win the presidency
Donald Trump has a way with words and
people I will be phenomenal to the women
I have many Hispanics working for me
many many Hispanics we're rounding them
up in a very humane way in a very nice
way and they're gonna be happy vote for
me because we're gonna make America
great again but the media don't get him
and he doesn't appreciate it
some of the media is among the worst
people I've ever met and I made a pretty
good percentage is really a terrible
group of people scott adams prolific
author blogger and creator of Dilbert
thinks they're all getting trolled I'm
saying I see a flamethrower
I think the flamethrower guy wins in the
stick fight though he doesn't support
Trump or any other candidate he believes
that Trump is in fact a master wizard
the idea of the master wizard hypothesis
says that there are some people in the
world living people who were masters of
persuasion they've got a linguistic gift
for influencing people and they're using
actual technique what I saw in Trump was
someone who was highly trained and then
a lot of the things that the media were
reporting as sort of random insults and
bluster and just Trump being Trump look
to me like a lot of deep technique that
I recognized from the fields of hypnosis
and persuasion so let me give you a few
examples of the technique that Trump
uses there's something that I call the
linguistic kill shot and what that is is
a engineered set of words that
essentially changes an argument or ends
it so decisively I call it a kill shot
so one of the ones that Donald Trump
used was when he referred to Jeb Bush
being a low-energy guy very very low
energy so low-energy that every time you
watch him you fall asleep not take more
energy tonight I like that or when he
referred to Carly Fiorina as a robot
like a robot bah Papa like a robot or
Carson is nice Ben is a nice man he's
actually a really nice guy all of these
have the same quality their words you
haven't heard in the political realm
before so they're sort of virginal words
that he can use the way he wants they
don't have a lot of baggage with them
but they also perfectly fit what you are
already thinking about
these people they weren't random insults
and once you hear it you could never get
it out of your mind that's how powerful
it is you notice that he insults people
that come at him I'm telling you anybody
that that would view it that way has to
be a little bit of a deviant and he also
compliments people quite effusive ly
when they're nice or at least they're
not bothering him I think they like me
in a certain way which is nice it's
always nice to be liked so what he's
done is he's created a fairly large gap
between insulting Trump where he'll take
you down or being nice to him we will
take you up it sounds like you're saying
I have leverage over the Republican
Party so they better be nice to me well
essentially I want to be treated fairly
that's true I do want to not nice you go
against him
you know there's a little bit more to
lose an anchor is something big and
visual and emotional that takes you off
of whatever you were thinking before
just because it's a bigger thought so
for example when Trump was in his first
debate you've called women you don't
like fat pigs dogs slobs and disgusting
animals
that was a terrible thing for him to
answer with a direct answer but he
didn't do that your Twitter account only
Rosie O'Donnell immediately you go to
this big visual everybody knows her his
base probably has a negative feeling
about her and all the headlines became
about Rosie O'Donnell instead of his
Trump a sexist I blurted at the name
Rosie O'Donnell and the place went crazy
and it really had a big impact on her
questioning kind of brilliant he does
the same thing with his idea for
immigration and for the wall the wall is
this big visual magnificent thing in
your head it will be a real wall it'll
be a wall that works it'll actually be a
wall that will look good a big beautiful
powerful wall it can have a gate it can
have a door I have a tremendous
beautiful wide open door nice big door
even if you hate it it's still big and
visual and it takes all the attention in
that direction and that's what he wants
what are the things that Trump does
really well is he uses a type of
linguistic judo for example there was
one interviewer said you're kind of a
whiner rich Lowry says that you are the
most fabulous
Winer i in the world and instead of
saying no I'm not a whiner Trump
embraced it like judo he took the force
of the label and said I am a whiner and
I'm a whiner and I keep whining and
whining until I win and I'm gonna win
for the country and I'm gonna make our
country great again so he changed whiner
into the biggest voice for change and he
did it with just a few words it's
amazing
likewise if Trump says anything about
capitalism in the context of the Pope
it's just now going to come out right so
instead Trump doesn't take the bait what
do you say in response to the Pope I'd
say I just wants to get you it's such a
big bold thought I'm gonna have to scare
the public all your attention just goes
to that he uses vagueness as a tool this
is a trick I learned in hypnosis class
sometimes you want to tell the story in
a way that lets people fill in the
blanks with whatever would make them the
happiest so if Trump has a vague idea
about foreign policy it was like I have
the Chinese banks in my buildings they
listen to me they respect to me you're a
vague idea about the economy my economy
will expand so rapidly we're going to
take jobs back from other countries
you're a vague idea about how they
handle Isis I would end Isis forcefully
people fill in the blanks with brilliant
plans that are their own plans it's more
of a strategy than you imagined it is
but he has another thing going for him
he's developed the Trump persona over
many years he can do what nobody can do
as a politician he can change his mind
raising the Social Security retirement
age to 70 that stole your point not
anymore you can say I'm not gonna tell
you what I'll do I'll just hire good
people to do it I have the smartest
people on Wall Street lined up already
and he also can tell a joke he can be
outrageous I'm worried if you're
president I'll get deported all right
that's what I would be well we're gonna
try like hell to keep you here built you
see apple pie and flags and eagles
coming out of his ass when he talks a
lot of people ask me what could bring
down
little truck probably there's no defense
and that's why I've predicted he
probably will win the presidency based
just on skill I've said that if Trump
wins it might change how we see the
world not just how we see politics but
how we see humans and how how humans are
influenced and how little reason has
anything to do with what we do in my
book had to fail at almost everything
and still win big I write about the
moist robot idea it's the idea that
humans are essentially robots that are
made of meat in that world emotion and
influence and all the techniques that
Trump uses are really the only things
that explain what's happening in the
world reason will never be a satisfying
explanation of what you see we're gonna
build a wall and we're gonna create a
border it's gonna be a great wall and
it's not going to be very expensive I
find it terribly interesting that you
can defend an entirely different view of
the world with the same data that's used
to defend the standard model so whenever
I can do that
I'm so there because as soon as you
realize that the model you've been
looking at maybe isn't so firm as you
thought then you're free